all right everybody
this is it it's september 14th tuesday
september 14 20
21 if you haven't been playing along at
home today is a big day
for me
the people of california the people of
the united states and thus
the people of the world that's right the
california recall election is today
as you know i've already voted my team
has already voted many of my friends
have already voted a lot of other people
have already voted i suspect some people
have voted more than once i suspect some
people have already mailed in their
ballot and will still vote
but shenanigans aside today is actually
a huge day i think in
the present and the history of the
united states of america obviously i'm
supporting larry elder we don't have to
go through all the stuff that you guys
know already about why i love the guy
and why i think he's the right answer
you already got all that stuff i'm gonna
show you some of the media hit pieces in
just a moment to really exemplify how
hardcore they're going against him on
top of the fact that old joe biden
showed up yesterday and a bunch of other
things
but there is a chance today there is a
chance i'm not saying it's a good chance
although i actually do think that it is
in my heart of hearts i think there's
such
such on the ground support that the
media will never cover that this does
feel a little bit to me like trump 2016
but has the machine just learned better
on how to destroy people has the have
the algorithms and the way they can
manipulate the news thus manipulating
people and manipulate votes and all of
those things has that all gotten so much
stronger in our faces that it will make
it impossible perhaps and perhaps it
would be purely legit and he would lose
but i i have faith that it can be
possible and it's like man if we could
do this today
here in california what a signal we
could send across america and then the
world right like what a signal it would
be
to say we defeated one of their
worst authoritarian progressive blue
nightmares one of the guys who destroyed
one of the greatest states in america
one of the biggest economies in the
world not just for a state but for a
country it has a huge huge economy
california bigger than most countries
that's the point and he's decimated it
and you know all the reasons and we
could send a signal
that could go across the world right now
and say the people can fight back maybe
it can happen maybe it can happen so
obviously we're going to start with all
of that stuff and then i'm doing a bunch
of media appearances throughout the day
all about the recall the second story
we're going to cover is just
i hate to even bother talking about her
because she's just such an abject awful
human being but there was this met gala
yesterday
at the metropolitan museum in new york
city and aoc showed up in a uh in a
dress we'll show you the video and some
stills in a few minutes but uh she's
just terrible and i just wanted to show
you that once again aoc is just terrible
then we'll do some covid stuff
but obviously today is mostly about the
recall by the way i do want to mention
real quick and then we'll get going here
that yesterday was our channel's biggest
day ever
on youtube believe it or not despite
whatever tricks they're doing with
algorithms and everything else yesterday
like by a long shot in terms of our
total channel views and i believe
subscriptions and just a whole bunch of
other metrics that we track it was our
biggest day ever so thank you guys for
your support like people are listening
one way or another right doesn't mean
you get wins every day and i do have
hope i really do but like people are
listening and and you know it takes time
to build something that's real and
something that's good and you're
building it with me all right before we
get to everything today i want to talk
to you guys about marley spoon you know
now that i'm back on the grid it's time
to get back to normal and that means
back to being busy i'm looking forward
to simplifying my kitchen routine with
martha stewart and marley spoon
america's best tasting meal kit martha
stewart and marley spoon deliver quick
and convenient meals designed by chefs
to be ready in about 30 minutes the
subscription is always flexible so you
can skip or pause whenever you want and
orders can be customized every week to
suit tastes and special diets i was
scrolling through their online menu
earlier today and the coffee rubbed
steak and lemon rosemary chicken meals
caught my eye and those are just some of
the options for this week so if you're
like me and tired of rush meals and
boring dinners let martha stewart and
marley spoon change that go to
marleyspoon.com and use promo code ruben
to get a hundred bucks off your first
order that's a hundred bucks of free
food just for using promo code reuben
it's a game changer everything's
delicious delicious everything's ready
fast
and everybody wants to return for
seconds check them out at
marleyspoon.com and now back to me okay
big day callie big day like i've given
this thing everything i've got like
whatever happens
you know i i feel good because you have
to fight for things that you believe in
and and i really do think it could
happen i know that's nuts but i i
believe i believe it could happen
despite the evil machine that we're
going to talk about in just a sec well
first off if you don't think it could
happen well then why would they be
having barack obama do an ad where he
refused to say larry
elder's name even though he was talking
about larry elder why did they send
kamala harris to california why did they
send elizabeth warren and amy klobuchar
and as larry elder has pointed out
nobody can say anything good about gavin
no one ever says anything good about
gavin because there's nothing that they
can say it's good oh the economy is
great here oh the homeless situation's
great here oh the drug use oh the house
prices like it's all terrible so they
never say anything good about them they
give these strange vague platitudes
about gavin newsom why you have to keep
him in office so this is biden yesterday
in california what we're not going to
show you just because we had a
jam-packed showday is that biden showed
up and you know biden never gets crowds
to show up at his events but he actually
did this time of course it was a crowd
of people uh yelling f biden and go home
biden and we don't like you biting but
it was good that anyone showed up for
joe that was nice but here's a little
bit of joe's passionate speech about why
you should vote for gavin newsom all of
you know the last year i got to run
against the real donald trump
well
this year
this year the leading republican running
for governor
is a uh the closest thing
to a trump
clone that i've ever seen in your state
i really mean it
and uh
he's leading the other team
he's the clone
of donald trump
can you imagine
him being
governor of this state
you can't
let
that
happen
yes you can if you want to live in a
free state and make decisions for
yourself and not listen to these
authoritarian nut bags who lie about
everything and i suppose joe biden
either has dementia or is racist because
as he's calling larry elder a trump
clone he refuses to even say his name
like he's voldemort so he's very very
scared and that's why they had to get
joe to come out and get on a plane and
have to go out and speak which he
doesn't like to do because he's usually
napping
okay
god he's such a freaking creep
so that was joe biden's speech yesterday
and the fact that he refuses to even say
larry elder's name
does that feel a little racist to you
maybe right like we don't like to play
the identity politics game we don't like
to call everybody racist but think about
what's happening in america right now
basically all of america except
the progressives want there to be a
black governor of california and not
because he's black he just happens to be
black he's got good ideas but the
progressives are the one who refused to
say the name of the man that they lie
and slander
and
completely attack and endlessly
dishonest manner they're kinda the
racist uh well right before we started
the show gavin newsom tweeted out this
incredible video they got joe biden to
put up a video on twitter and it's
incred i mean this is when you talk
about high energy like get out there and
vote stuff this is the video that gavin
newsom just tweeted of old joe vote no
on the recall election today to keep
california moving forward
as i said they can't say anything good
about gavin newsom all they can say are
vaguely bad dishonest things about larry
elder without saying his name joe of
course was reading off a teleprompter
there take a look at his eyes let's look
again vote now on the recall election
today to keep california moving forward
let's do it again
vote no on the recall election today to
keep california moving forward
god these people are horrible they're
just like horrible people that that want
to control you forever keep california
moving forward that's all they can say
we're moving forward you know what the
thing about moving forward is sometimes
you're moving forward and there might be
a ditch or there might be a cliff and if
you move forward with your only regard
to moving forward you're going to fall
into that ditch or you're going to go
over that cliff and that's exactly what
the progressives are trying to do with
america we're going forward it's
progress except you don't want progress
just for the sake of progress you don't
go forward just for the sake of going
forward i want somebody that's driving
the car that's like oh you know what
there we got a problem let's turn the
car a little less maybe you turn it
think about a different way oh it turns
out there's a bridge over there let's go
over that bridge that's what larry elder
that's what sensible mature people who
should be governing us want to do but
we're going to move forward we're going
to go forward no matter what we're going
to progress no matter what and it is the
slow
descent to hell that will actually
rapidly escalate that these people are
trying to get us to we're going to go
forward it's kind of going slow for all
then it's going to speed up then we go
down the ditch and we end up in their
socialist nightmare but i just think
like that low maybe we have to show it
again i mean that low energy he's
reading off a teleprompter for four
seconds and that's what gavin newsom
tweeted as if it's like any sort of
endorsement that will get anyone excited
one more time vote no on the recall
election today to keep california moving
forward
absolutely pathetic but if you don't
think that joe biden you know not saying
larry elder's name and then reading off
a teleprompter for a four second video
is bad enough and if you don't think
that barack obama who also wouldn't say
larry elder's name the ad that he put up
on uh on youtube was bad enough and the
lies that kamala harris said about larry
elder if you don't think any of this
stuff is bad enough if you want to
understand how the true machine operates
and i'm probably going to get shot after
this show but we're going all in today
you know if you want to understand how
the machine how big tech is manipulating
truth and how it is affecting elections
well i did a crazy thing today and again
i'm not a journalist i'm just a man with
a computer and i googled larry elder and
let's put the video up here i googled
larry elder i click news and i want you
to look at those headlines you can look
at them for yourself i don't have to
read them to you every single one i
think except for the uh the insider one
right there is negative larry elder's
conceding larry elder's calling for
cheating nothing about larry elder's
ideas nothing about the strong support
the incredible rallies
none of that really extraordinary stuff
every single one
of those stories is negative about larry
elder and by the way it's not just that
that started today
on election day we know this has been
going on for weeks and weeks and weeks
the los angeles times which as far as i
know is a white supremacist newspaper
now uh completely has lied about larry
elder all the way including calling him
the black face of white supremacy and
when they had the incident at venice
where a woman in a gorilla costume threw
an egg at him they put up a picture
which implied that he attacked somebody
he was actually touching her face she's
a larry elder supporter and he was
hugging her if you actually watch the
video these are horrible horrible people
and that's what they do but the worst
one of those the absolute worst one of
those was the daily beast look at that
headline from the daily beast larry
elder preemptively concedes defeat
launches voter fraud site
okay
that is 100 percent lie larry elder has
not conceded but this is what they do
now are there websites uh that are
tracking whether there's voter fraud yes
do they have anything to do with the
larry elder campaign i swear to you i
swear to you i do not know actually tim
poole just messaged me right before
asking me if i knew i honestly do not
know okay um but i would have no problem
with a candidate that wants to shore up
an election in a deeply corrupt state
being like oh yeah could we have a
website where you could maybe send some
information by the way yesterday on the
show i asked you guys to send in things
if you if you had any evidence of voter
fraud or anything and people have been
and we've been compiling them and
sending it over to some of the lawyers
that i know are looking into this stuff
that's not saying that there's
widespread fraud or any of those things
but we're allowed in a free society as
long as we remain free not much longer
we're allowed to discuss these things
we're allowed to have websites but the
daily beast put up a headline pull it up
one more time for me that says larry
elder preemptively concedes defeat
well that now is all over twitter that
is all over twitter right now and that
seems to me like it might be election
engineering election interference and i
thought
jack
from twitter right jack dorsey remember
when you suppressed the hunter biden
story because you thought that might
affect the election well on election day
here in california you're letting that
story run wild i tweeted at jack he has
not responded to me he did agree to do
the show many times over the years and
then just would never give us a date but
jack if you're watching the show i know
you're a good decent non-partisan
american and you just want to use
twitter as an open space for people to
get information out there and you surely
wouldn't be manipulating elections in
any way so i would i would hope that you
would look into that sort of election
misinformation because i remember and i
know that most people's memories have
been obliterated by endlessly scrolling
on the tv but i remember on the on the
phone there but i remember a time at a
presidential election that wasn't too
long ago when misinformation related to
the election would get you you'd get a
warning or a suspension or a banning
well now the daily beast which purports
to be a place of journalism
journalism
is saying that the
main leading candidate in the recall
race has uh gotten out of the race think
that's problem
think that's the problem all right you
guys get it listen last thing i'll say
on the election before the end of the
show is if you have not voted and you
live in california please vote and
please vote in person
and no matter what happens like fighting
for what you believe in it's it's the
most it's just the most important thing
you can do i really believe that like
you know since i've been back from the
grid i've given this thing everything i
got and i was fighting for larry before
and i i told you i did an event with
larry when i was off the grid also
um i i feel great right now like i
really do like i feel proud of what i
have done here and if at the end of the
day if joe biden and barack obama and
kamala harris and gavin newsom beat
larry elder me scott baio and uh john
voigt it's like all right we tried and
whether it's legit or not we tried and
all you can do in a free society a free
society gives you the chance to try and
fight for what you believe in i really
do think it could happen i i really do
and whether it happens or not
you know
it's getting people excited again
getting people to realize that there are
better
better ways than this this as i keep
calling it this this slow but will be a
rapidly escalating descent to hell that
the progressives are taking us on and we
know it we all know it we all know this
is going in the wrong direction
and and when old joe gets up there and
refuses to say larry's name
and says that no we just have to move
forward and we just have to have
progress they're not saying anything all
they're saying is just give us more
power they're they're never saying oh
it's good it's good and we can maybe
make it better they're saying just give
us more power and behave and stay in
your basements and keep your masks on
and get injections every two weeks these
things are all connected they're all
connected
and that's a perfect segue to our second
story speaking of vapid lefties who
don't believe anything they say and are
just usurping your attention for power
let's talk about aoc uh so the big met
gala was yesterday and i'm told guys you
can correct me if i'm wrong on this
michael i maybe i may be mistaken but
are we in the middle of a pandemic
worldwide pandemic very serious stuff
connor have you heard about this thing
people wearing mass everywhere all right
so my guys have heard about it
supposedly there's this crazy pandemic
happening where everyone's in masks
nightmare death everywhere yet for some
reason the progressives managed to all
show up to the met gala yesterday
dressed mostly as clowns actually we'll
show you some well let's just we have an
image or a video of aoc what do we got
let's throw something on my god
video of aoc rich what a model aoc
i didn't know you model as well
damn
oh my god aoc tax the rich what a motto
oh my god god these people are awful so
just to be clear this is a thirty
thousand dollar per ticket event okay
we're in the middle of a pandemic you'd
think that maybe these people wouldn't
be flaunting their elitism uh aoc of
course she is the worst type of elitist
because she already is an elitist right
she's never done anything other than
become a congresswoman to me you don't
get a lot of credit for that especially
the way she did it by by sort of just
using america against itself she rails
against capitalism and freedom and
everything that is good but she has no
problem partying with these people and
yes i get it but she's but dave she's
she's telling them tax the rich she's
saying fight the power uh no she's doing
this to just troll everybody like if you
think trump was a troll aoc is aoc is a
vile vile troll because she's trying to
destroy the very system that has allowed
her to become relevant as disgusting
maybe capitalism isn't great someone
like aoc could become relevant aoc did
not pay for her ticket by the way masks
were only required inside but as you can
see in some of the videos
masks were not required inside even for
the or mass were not required inside for
the attendees like aoc and the other
elitists but all the staff that was
serving them had to wear masks and i
mentioned this
when i was away in mexico during the
break that i was at a resort where the
guests did not have to wear a mask and
all the staff did and it really was
making me think we're going to end up in
a class war too i mean there's so many
things wrong right now but this mass
thing's
going to become a class thing that the
people working to serve the elite will
be put in mass at the resort i was at i
told every single person that brought me
a drink or served this dinner i said you
don't have to wear the mask for me and i
would ask people to just smile
occasionally and nobody wanted to take
their math down they want to keep their
jobs but this is what someone like her
is she will hobnob around
multi-multi-millionaires and
billionaires and by the way i don't
think they're inherently bad because
they have money they're probably pretty
decent people who in many cases are very
philanthropic and pay most of the taxes
we'll get back we'll get to that in a
sec but she does that while trying to
destroy the very thing that allows these
pathetic reporters to slobber all over
her as she's saying tax the rich but
i thought we'd do a little a little
research on this tax the rich so do we
not do we not tax the rich in the united
states i mean is it true that the rich
aren't paying taxes and everyone else is
well we've got an image
from something called the irs this is
the internal revenue service i think
these people know something about taxes
from what i understand and i want you to
really look at this image and perhaps
you'll screenshot this and send this to
other people because aoc says that we
that you know this is what they always
say this is what bernie says this is
what dementia joe says this is what
they're always saying that the the rich
have to pay their fair share the rich
have to pay more etc etc i want you to
look at that top right area so if you
look at top five to ten percent top two
to five percent top one percent you got
eleven percent sixteen twenty one uh
they're paying basically fifty percent
of the taxes so if you're making over a
hundred fifty two thousand dollars
which is a significant amount of people
they're paying about fifty percent of
the taxes is that not their fair share
is that not their fair share the top one
percent
those are people making over 540 000
like you're doing real well that's great
you're probably doing something
worthwhile they're paying 21 so the top
1
pay 21
if you're making over 152 000
you are basically paying 50 percent of
the taxes and i'll let you guys analyze
this for yourselves but do you really
think they're not paying their fair
share do you think that we're not taxing
the rich and do you think that perhaps
if we tax the rich more just so that
people like aoc will have more money for
her ridiculous government programs that
just waste and accomplish nothing and
create a bigger and bigger state that
does nothing other than suck off all of
us and not suck off in the good way uh
do you think
do you think do you think uh that she's
just using this as more power that she
can give to herself to wear her
ridiculous dress and throw it all in our
face like it's just so obvious i don't
like aoc
have i made myself clear on that i don't
like yeah that was clear okay all right
let's talk about this covet situation
because uh you know aoc sure she's
hanging out with the uh with the elite
you know 30. 30 000 tickets
but we are told that there is this
pandemic and uh there is now a fight
which has broken out between joy reid
and nicki minaj now joy reid i don't
watch msnbc but i have reference to her
every now and again because out of all
the ridiculous clowns that are on
mainstream media and on these cable news
channels i would say joy read is
probably at the top you can get
video and still images and text of joy
read saying one thing one day the next
thing the next day and it's not because
she's evolved it's because she's a
ridiculous partisan clown so first we've
got video from her show yesterday going
after nicki minaj nicki minaj if you
don't know she's a singer not really my
thing you know i like frank sinatra but
you know she's a popular singer amongst
the kids and joy reid's going after
nicki minaj so we're going to show you
the video and then i'll explain why
she's doing it here's joy reid and
people like nicki minaj i have to say
this
you have a platform sister that is 22
million followers okay i have two
million followers you have 22 million
followers on twitter for you to use your
platform to encourage our community to
not protect themselves and save their
lives my god sister you could do better
than that you got that platform
it's a blessing it's a blessing that you
got that that people listen to you and
they listen to you more they listen to
me
for you to use your platform to put
people in the position of dying from a
disease they don't have to die from oh
my god as a fan as a hip-hop fan as
somebody who was your fan i'm so sad
that you did that so sad that you did
that sister oh my god
joy reads sister i got something to tell
you as dave rubin right over here
because you got a platform you got two
million followers on twitter these are
not the brightest people on the planet
and you've got a show on msnbc not a
great network but you've got influence
girl so what are you why are you saying
that why is she saying that to
uh nicki minaj well
you ray remember this tweet i've shown
it to you guys about 10 times let's pull
up the tweet because nicki minaj
commented on this tweet this is joy
reads
opus right this is her most famous tweet
this is joy reid when donald trump was
president i mean will anyone anyone at
all ever fully i guess you're saying
fully trust the cdc again and who on
god's earth would trust the vaccine
approved by the fda how do we get a
vaccine distributed after this broken
trumpist nonsense has infected
everything even if biden wins my god
my god has joy reid seen what joy reid
tweeted
joy reid's got a platform joy read
better freaking you know go after joy
reid because this is crazy so then nicki
minaj
retweeted that tweet and she said this
a lying homophobic i'll just skip that
word i guess i can join in on the
reindeer games too right people can go
on tv and lie on me i can report on them
too right doesn't have to be truths it
can be half truths uncle tomania asks
who on earth would trust the usfda guys
at joy and read and then she retweeted
that tweet i just showed you there this
was all sparked if you you know i don't
like to do these little twitter battles
like that's not really what i'm trying
to make as the main issue here this was
all sparked by basically nicki minaj had
sent out a tweet saying that one of her
friends i think in trinidad uh took the
vaccine and something happened to his
testicles and she basically literally i
think his testicles got bigger they got
bigger and smaller
it was bigger big thank you
we have a series of hand motions during
the show so the guys don't have to talk
but i just got the bigger testicles
signal thank you uh so apparently this
is what nicki minaj is saying one of her
friends got big testicles after the uh
have to get in the vaccine there and uh
and then basically she was just saying
just don't be bullied into getting the
vaccine that's what nicki minaj said so
anyway i illustrate this fight not
because i want to talk about joy and
read or even care about nicki minaj
really um do i do i know any nicki minaj
songs so like what's her big song
she's got she's got a couple big ones
that's what they're telling me big is
the testicles or what all right the
point is guys um
i don't like joy read i don't like aoc i
don't like joy read i don't like gavin
newsom maybe tomorrow i'm just gonna do
a show where i'll just list the people i
don't like that would be a good show oh
but there is a guy that i do like
speaking of covid this is this guy ron
desantis down in florida he is the
governor of florida i think it's very
possible that he will be the next
president of the united states which
would be pretty spectacular he has done
everything he has been able to do in the
last year and a half to keep his state
open allow people to make decisions for
themselves and you know as we've talked
about many times he has the second
oldest population in the united states
in florida and yet their death rates in
many cases have been lower than states
that are much younger they have good
weather there so he wanted to keep
things open he's just done a great job
and he's fighting the machine to the
best of his ability well check out this
video that
from yesterday
where he makes a really interesting
point about vaccine mandates and whether
or not people have had kovid before
these mandates this is not about science
because if it was about science you
would recognize the infection conferred
immunity that people like jonathan has
israel did a study they said it was much
much more protective than the pfizer
vaccine was cleveland clinic did a study
same thing every single credible study
always shows that it provides good
protection and so that's just the
reality so i don't support mandates at
all but if you're doing mandate based
off this if you're really following
science you would acknowledge
this natural immunity and instead they
ignore it and force somebody who already
has protection to take uh to take a
medical treatment they may not like and
so uh it's really about using government
power control to mandate
much more than it is about the
underlying medical issues that are
involved and i think that is the perfect
example of why if you do not acknowledge
that you are not following science
truth
isn't truth refreshing
isn't truth easy
doesn't truth make you want to sit up
and put your shoulders back and fight
for the right things everything he said
there was true infection conferred
immunity we all know this everyone knows
this ask and ask your doctor
don't trust me ask your doctor when
people get kobid they then have immunity
to covid some people get a great
immunity to kovid some people less some
people it sort of runs out quickly
there's all sorts of versions of that
but as uh desantis is pointing out the
idea that everyone should have to get
this shot regardless of whether they
have immunity not and he references this
israeli study where they're realizing
that yes if you've had kovid you
probably have more antibodies and we
also now know it is just true don't ban
me from youtube that the vaccines are
not working as promised when the
vaccines were coming out joe biden if
you get the vaccine you're good to go
well now they're they want they're
talking lockdowns again they've got
everybody in masks by the way they don't
do the masks themselves and we showed
you the video yesterday a ridiculous
video of biden wearing the mask while
he's walking but then when he goes up
and talks to people he takes the mask
down literally touches people then
touches his mouth i mean the whole
thing's just an extraordinary farce but
what desantis just said there was true
so what do we do with that what do we do
with an ever-encroaching
federal government that wants to be part
of all of our lives and in this case
i've got that ever-encroaching federal
government coming to my state to ensure
that this ridiculous buffoon gavin
newsom stays as governor it's like that
is our challenge man and i don't know i
don't know exactly what we do with that
but i know we keep fighting i know
that's at least part of it that's what i
intend to do
all right guys uh please
if you have not what are you doing vote
yes to recall evil disney cartoon gavin
newsom and then select larry elder if
you do it here in los angeles don't
forget on your electronic voting machine
you have to tap more eight times to get
to larry elder's name eight times yes
that's right if you don't believe me
check out the video that we did right
after i voted a couple days ago
also my full uh interview with rose
mcgowan is up right now she drops is it
no it's part one sorry oh sorry part two
is up right now uh the full episode's up
of course at
reubenreport.locals.com oh and by the
way we just started doing this over the
last couple days we're now doing live
chat
on locals via the app or via the desktop
reubenreport.locals.com
so you guys can actually chat during the
show you can have a second screen and
you can chat during the show and it gets
rid of all the bots and the trolls and
the haters and all of that stuff and
this is just one of a series of things
that we're going to be doing that are
going to escalate and uh and broaden
what we're doing with locals related to
this show and a whole bunch more on the
way so you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
all right it's a big day i've got i've
got a whole bunch of media hits um and
i feel good i really feel good i really
believe there's a chance i really
believe that the most important thing
you can do on this planet is fight for
what you believe in i believe that larry
elder is the right guy to do this
i believe that this system is screwy i
believe that
the machine is against us but
this is what humans do like this is the
story of what humans do and by the way i
don't think that our salvation comes
through politics but sometimes you've
got to use politics
to get a little of your personal
salvation so that you can live the way
you want to so i hope
that
you've heard some of this and you've
incorporated some of this into your life
and i hope if you're in california you
vote and i hope if you're not in
california you you see what a disaster
this place has become
and and you fight to make sure that
wherever you live doesn't become such a
disaster
i will be back tomorrow and uh we shall
see it's either it's gonna be quite a
day i mean
if i have a bottle of tequila
on the uh on the set here you'll know
why uh but i have hope i really do so
elect elder dot com thanks for watching
and we'll see you tomorrow
you